boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
today we have the incredible pleasure of
sitting down with Tony Lane Casserly
hello thank you for joining us thank you
for coming on the show really appreciate
it
yeah this is gonna be so much fun we're
be talking about the importance of
decentralized governance in our world
yeah which is very interesting because
we've had what like 200 almost 50 years
of this u.s. governance and it's been
like pretty good the Constitution's good
but it's centralized and now we have
blockchain we have all this technology
that helps us decentralize things well
it's beyond even decentralization it's
more the idea that when you look at any
kind of theory and the theory in
principle and the theory in practice are
so far removed from themselves that
they're actually creating a cliff of
divide that divide is actually going to
propagate through the minds of people
that are practicing the philosophy
because what we believe democracy is or
what we're taught democracy is if we're
even taught what democracy is
and what democracy has become in many
instances in practice when you shift the
incentives toward you know that of
capitalism instead of actually like the
humanization of what is meant to be the
collective good the good of the Commons
then you're fragmenting what you're
you're fragmenting belief and in
fragmenting that belief what people are
doing is inserting the idea that belief
is not belief in the functionality of
the system belief is not the belief in
the principle of democracy believe his
belief in the principle that you
associate with your self-identity and in
fracturing that principle of you know
here's you know are the good of the
system and then here's my is
self-interested good what happens is we
pre create partisan politics and that's
we know why we have these Republicans
and Democrats and why people say I hate
all Democrats because I personally feel
pro-gun or I feel Pro you know a
pro-life or whatever or I feel anti it
either of those things in Pro marijuana
and we say that because I believe in
this certain thing myself
that must mean that I believe in this
thing politically and eaten in that
entire train of logic right all people
are doing from the minute they start
saying that until the second they finish
it's just them literally sacrificing
their agency and targeting other people
instead of actually looking at a systems
functionality and questioning whether
that system is living up to its
principle and that destroys the the
destruction of the principle of the
system in turn has been destroying the
principles of our own humanity so you
know Aristotle didn't say like democracy
is it
he wasn't like democracy is like that's
my life mate democracy he said of the
systems we know that exist democracy is
the best it's the best of what we know
right but what if the best of what you
know is you know I've only in my life
ever shopped in a very small local
Walmart and there are no local farms or
what if the best of what you know is
that you know what if the best of what
you know is essentially something that's
bad for you something that's maybe
filled with preservatives or chemicals
that you don't know about I'm not trying
to dog on Walmart here I'm just giving
an example of the way that you know the
the underlying mechanics behind the way
that we've thought about production and
consumption have driven us away from the
good of what is human life what is the
good for human life and what is the good
for my life right so yeah I mean it's
all of this all of this symbolism is
coming to a head
and what blockchain really represents in
so many different ways is our ability to
to recreate and to redefine that
symbolism and to say are any of these
Western systems all right we haven't
always used these systems right like how
do you think we managed our societies in
like Sumerian times like these super
advanced civilizations like the Aztec
like the Maya the Egyptians right they
all have pretty similar models but their
connection was always based on something
bigger than what they are and whenever
you're only focusing on what you are
sudden you feel like you're very big and
everything else seems like it's either
very small where the bigger picture
doesn't connect with you because you're
not imagining anything outside of what
exists just in your own very narrow
perception so yeah I think what
blockchain represents is not you know
the idea of its it can represent many
ideas but it's a technology technology
is used by humans humans generally
respond to the incentives we create for
them so if we create better incentives
in our technology then we can see a
shift in human behavior if we change
human behavior then maybe we're one step
closer to peace but the healing starts
in here yes the healing totally starts
within and the decentralization is going
to cause a good amount of healing in our
future
you mentioned oh as you were going there
you said that we have this new sort of
conspicuous consumption capitalism
that's kind of taking over this ego is
getting pumped up we've lost kind of
this sense of the cosmic perspective on
to our civilization these things all in
play are kind of causing what we're
seeing and then this whole polarization
of taking this thought and associating
it with ourselves to the degree of which
we will actually refused to even
empathize with the other person's
thought because we are so in our own
bias this is it's starting to get a
little bit what we're experiencing a
good amount of flux right now when all
of a sudden Connie can just come on to
Twitter and just be like yo like make
America great again and and everyone's
like whoa how that happened so there's
like a bunch of things happening in the
social fabric that are kind of
disruptive and I want to learn more
about exactly how we can how we can fix
this with decentralization and how
you're working on it's been a year at
culture now yeah and that's going and
there's differences for people too you
were telling me about this earlier for
somebody that's coming on to the to your
platform now it's on to this
decentralized platform that it's
different for somebody that's a refugee
that just had their home taken away from
them and
versus someone that is living in San
Francisco that wants to get their voting
record on the blockchain of their
identity on the blockchain so this is
much different yeah so I mean one Kanye
West is a performance artist Kanye West
is a performance artist Kanye West is
doing what every major media agency in
the world is doing
who wants control what he's doing is
he's playing with reality at a meta
level that's what Kanye is actually
doing he's messing with everyone's sense
of reality in a way that is so
unexpected that he has control every
it's he has the control because you
can't control what is unexpected that's
the only way actually that a lot of
people can either you can have control
in that way if you're a persona because
then you're a bit more impervious to
some of these like targeted grassroot
insurgent attacks like we were talking
about earlier and in doing that way
you're actually you're you're taking the
incentives at a micro level that people
are using to exploit media information
and persona and you're essentially
saying he's essentially saying nope and
he's taking on that at a macro level and
he's flipping it on its head literally
saying I care so little about what
people think of me because that is how
they control me I'm taking what Kanye is
doing is he's actually rebelling against
that mentality and saying I'm taking
control of my own life I personally
think that Kanye West and Kim Kardashian
are our broad-scale media geniuses and
watching even watching the growth I mean
you just have to really take a moment
and step back regardless of principle or
any of these things what they've done
from a meta perspective or the evolution
of their persona is absolutely
remarkable and not that not that it ever
would be
but shouldn't be understated they're the
genius that they both because that
shouldn't be understated because they
really are they really are shifting what
people perceive as reality and there
very few people that have enough control
over it to do that yes so it's a
it is literally a trip and what they're
realizing is that what's happening is
like it's it's it's literally like
realizing that everyone around you is on
opioids and you're like sitting up here
you're in like some kind of you know
ayahuasca but are like you know you're
in you're in this you know lucid you're
in this full lucid state and once you're
able to take that lucid perspective over
reality you're able to take all of the
people that are asleep and hopefully
shift them into something greater so
culture is actually a movement that I've
been working on for and that's what he
does like he's saying that rather than
being a slave to the culture that exists
around me I am literally taking this
into my own hands and I am just tired
and at any expense right I would do it
not that I would ever do things the same
way because I definitely wouldn't but
it's yeah I mean it's powerful right
it's powerful to have that level of
control over your own life especially
when you get that big yeah you know so
it's all you know there's a lot of it
the strategic and then there's some of
it that's just real and that's also what
makes it so interesting I've been
working on culture for the last like
actually five to seven years that's how
long you've been working on yourself
just under different names and it's but
you've been aware of blockchain
technology for that long
yeah bloch means pretty much been my
whole life in career I found blockchain
technology when I was twenty years old
so I was staying you know politics
economics my actual degree was in
advertising and propaganda theory mm-hmm
I noticed I thought that was super
interesting propaganda theory yeah
which is what we're gonna talk about in
a little bit also with media for sure
yeah oh yeah and then within the
framework of that propaganda theory I
was also studying politics economics and
philosophy I was basically just studying
I was in college but what I was learning
was I used colleges of resource so it's
not like I was like oh I take these
classes so I only read these books like
I just go around and get syllabi for
different classes and different reading
lists and I would just talk to people I
just talked to professors and I'd read
stuff and I've had questions and I'd ask
about those questions and I'd figure
things out so the quality of your life
Quadra questions yeah absolutely
absolutely and so and it's also if you
have resources at your big questions if
you have researched by the way talking
about hacking a simulation we can
definitely get into that mm-hmm
well even globalization and wealth
inequality and AGI and bio warfare and
how do we maximize human potential all
these freaking questions that all these
different diverse leaders in their
different fields let's test your
perspectives about them let's get these
thoughts to the world let's inspire more
people around the world to have these
conversations because what are we going
to do in the future how are we gonna
have these children be birthed in the
world so yeah what the importance of
this deep question and the importance of
blockchain technology to where are we
going yeah and yeah I mean I think these
are all questions that can't be answered
and they can be answered individually
from our perspectives but the future is
determined by all of us yes you know and
so yeah some have more power and control
like we were just talking about with
Connie and Kim well it depends on how
what is the level of I don't want to say
cosmic awareness but it's really like
how broad and how high how meta is your
perspective like how meta can you get in
terms of the way that you perceive
things because once you're able to take
who you are it's self transcendence and
remove it from the equation you learn a
lot more about what's actually happening
because you're not trying to process
things through the continual framework
of you you're removing you from the
equation and in removing the idea of
your own self identity to kind of riff
in the opposite direction of what I just
said when you're actually removing the
idea of your relationship to yourself
and your ego from an equation in a way
that allows you to transcend what would
be your normal perception you're able to
take in reality as it is it's like the
glass isn't half-empty it's not half
full
technically the glass is always full
because half of its filled with air but
you're literally looking at the glass as
interest is it is a glass there is water
in that glass like this is the state of
reality and in understanding that state
of reality you have more power to create
a state change you have more power to
shift that
because you're not perceiving things
through the framework of a perspective
your understanding that the sum of what
I am in my existence in my perspective
is an illusion of memory that I have
built over the course of my life that I
have lived and imagined because it's
every time we try and remember something
you know where our memory really exists
as dreams because every dream that we
have if we're exploring within our own
consciousness is created of the
framework of the memories that we have
stored in our physical bodies otherwise
all we would see is energy other if we
were just using our dream body and our
spirit body to traverse across the world
in the universe all we would see is just
the color of energy right in these
interactions and like these frames or
these vignettes but because we're living
in an environment where we actually have
a connection to the physical world
that's the only place memory is ever
real other than that it's the idea of
your existing in a period where your
imagined memory is based on what you
perceive is true to you and what you
perceive is true to you could be based
on something unprocessed you could be
perceiving truth based on an unprocessed
drama and then continuing to create that
truth because you still haven't
connected with the Godin you you know so
it's really important the foundation of
culture is actually based on the idea
that we as a society have to incentivize
self transcendence yeah as a philosophy
yeah if we're not going to have peace
inside of ourselves right at the top
yeah we can't have peace anywhere else
well I think the shape is changing right
and that's the the other thing that if
we talk about like shapes open people's
self transcendence they don't even have
their base physiological needs met right
that's got out we'd be this easily have
you been to India I mean they say in
India there's a lot of pain and very
little suffering because they're men
like my friend told me this story said I
was walking down the streets in India he
was doing this project for social good
and he says I see this man he's like
Harriet like Braille thin like ribs
everywhere just you know big old beard
and he's got a child with Kennedy's
missing teeth and it had just rained and
they're laying in a puddle and they're
and they're loving each other and
they're rolling around in this water
because it had rained and that meant
that they could have a shower they could
have a bath and they were joyous mm-hmm
right and that's because they have
reached that place of self transcendence
because the spiritual culture there is
very very very strong so you can reach
that place no matter how much you have
you can come up from you can have with
them when they have an issue with their
health it might be more difficult for
them to get an issue with their health
or maybe his child's issue with his
health
you could lose a child earlier due to
improper attendant tending of their
health and also to it's very good to be
spiritually connected enough to be able
to role but in the puddle so this is so
it's interesting that you bring it up
this I totally agree with you but I also
want to see there be some sort of the
base as well yeah yeah and I think that
that's going to be generated using
blockchain as a tool once information
can be quantified we will understand
that it is value once we can quantify
all forms of value we can actually
create wealth see time so so there's
last about five years though of going
through this process of figuring this
technology out and trying to bring it to
our world so the technology came to me
really early
it wasn't about figuring it out it was
finding it and feeling like the
questions had been answered
mm-hmm because I was looking at the
global economy going we've been printing
more death and we have wealth for like
50 or more years Venezuela is like 15th
on the cia's and one data for money
supply and they can't even stock that
grocery stores with food this is not
it's not even that it's not sustainable
it's that the illusion has gone so far
that the fracture in reality something
is gonna happen mm-hmm you know and we
had to have there's got to be there has
got to be something else like there's
got to be an answer and watching I
believe in so many ways is that answer
so when we think about it talk about
ideas like the infinite
you're like universal health care things
like that so if you think about DNA like
DNA is a storage molecule mm-hmm and you
have like processing elements within
your body like the amount of
transactions my body is making since
we've been sitting here is like you know
in in the in the billions trillions
however many transactions my body's been
making since we've literally just been
sitting down for this interview and if
we're able to actually look at our body
as a source of information right what is
because what is blotching actually like
what is Bitcoin
it's just ASIC chips that are mining and
solving super complex math problems that
increase it exponential rates and once
they're able to find the answers to
those problems it's actually generating
its therapy or know they're getting
Bitcoin for having solved that problem
as a computer you've got a decentralized
digital ledger yeah it's a it's a
decentralized digital ledger and in
being a decentralized digital ledger its
quantifying solutions to information
problems our body is literally just
information so let's say that if our
body is solving if we are solving
problems in our body or we're using our
body and the information in our body to
solve health problems it's the idea that
what if you had that with the people who
have really rare diseases are actually
really valuable because if we can figure
out if we can use or cross-reference
their own biological data with the other
basic biological database of other
people we might be able to find a
solution and a cure we might be able to
eliminate within within the next century
we may be able to eliminate disease
mm-hmm right so just the way the
information is reacting within our
biology if we could at least log that on
the ledger and then be able to analyze
the trigger of the pathology so many
people have been on the show talking
about biotech and we love that those
conversations there's so many other
applications of putting things on the
digital ledger we're talking about
voting earlier identity property
marriage there's so many things that can
go on there and there's so many cases of
people losing things that are theirs
due to there not being a paper trail of
it being theirs and who's in charge of
the paper trail it's a scent and when
it's a centralized paper trail
all of a sudden it can disappear with a
little bit of lobbying a little bit of
politics any of that and that's that's
that's unhealthy for someone's yeah you
know it's a serious serious transition
that we're in okay so now it's been a
couple years of analyzing this and
embodying it as your you know truth of
how you see the world and how you want
to solve a lot of the fractures that
we're experiencing I kind of want to
talk about the fractures a little bit
more because we're talking you talk
about solutions in the fractures as we
go but yeah this this fracture of the
media that's going on and it's nice
because we're both classify ourselves as
empaths you went to 30 straight days of
meditation Asia I went to 310 days of
meditation it's been one of the most
profound experiences of my life and it's
helped me really tune into another
person's being that there's a fullest
being and my own fullest being and so in
doing that I have learned that when I
see people be so polarized I try and
stay as calm and quantum as as possible
try to stay open-minded trying to stay
loving and caring ask really good
questions and so what we've seen is we
were talking abouts a little bit earlier
but this whole shift in people
manipulating the fabric of the media in
order to gain their own power agency
their own agency agency it's actually
and that's the the scarier thing the
scarier thing is that we have some
people manipulating the media at the the
mere attempt to just gain their agency
because we've created a world where you
have to be a certain way to be
successful or to be a man or it's be a
woman and all of that is utter BS it is
absolute and utter BS you don't have to
be anyone else's man but your own man
you don't have to be anyone else's woman
but your own woman and anyone who tells
you differently
they're afraid don't buy into it people
will try to sell you fear everywhere you
go it's not worth it it's not worth it
it's not worth it to make that kind of a
deal just let it go just literally let
it go yeah I mean the fractures are in
some ways I believe that it is our duty
and responsibility to heal these
structures and that's another core
thesis reciprocity and restoration are
two of the Cora thesis is underneath the
technology that that we're working on
and it's the idea that if you look at
the governance and the boxing in space
right now Bitcoin forked because of a
social fracture because of a social
political fracture and also because of
grassroots psychological insurgency
because we had paid trolls come in to
the reddit community as early as 2013
Manning 5200 reddit accounts when the
community was small and going in to
empower essentially the voices of trolls
and in doing that start to fragment the
community from within itself it's
pervasive it happened everywhere because
it was a study of reddit is do they know
yeah they're I don't know I haven't
called Alex or something but it is their
claim that 5,200 you know this was not
someone from reddit
I know yeah but but reddit analyzed the
bots accounts this is no no no no no no
this was so this was a report there's
the best media publication that ever
existed in the Bitcoin and blockchain
world was a publication called coin fire
they were real journalists and that's
why they got attacked they actually had
someone tried like DDoS like they were
just trying to shut them down
it was coin fire was the most authentic
high integrity publication that existed
in our industry and the site got shut
down but the reporters are still out
there well and they had someone they
contacted me about this story because I
you know co-founded and was the CEO of
coin Telegraph and they therefore the
first operational CEO ever
and they called me and they essentially
said you know like we need help we need
help and I'm like what's going on and
they said you know we're being attacked
right now because we're we're getting
this information and we're releasing
this story and I was like alright we'll
tell me more and the story that came out
was the most it was one of the most
remarkable things they had ever seen or
read it was just someone who felt guilty
it was literally and they had been known
for being the most high integrity
journalistic publication in the industry
and someone essentially just contacted
them and said I will give you the logins
and the passwords to all of these
accounts and they gave them it was they
gave them the passwords and logins to 50
different accounts they've been some of
them purchased some had been operational
for eight years
yeah they had all been posting so there
were posts it looks like this was a real
person because at one point in time they
actually had been right and so you don't
know like it looks like oh this person's
interested in like they have automated
posts in life makes it more difficult to
tell if they're a bot or a human they
were but that's the thing is that these
aren't BOTS they were operated by humans
these 5200 no these are not robots
they're networks of psychological
insurgency that are built by real people
that are Manning fifty to a hundred
accounts on reddit and have purchased
accounts from other real people men
women different backgrounds different
interests and are maintaining a normal
posting schedule there and then using
that same voice to fragment the Bitcoin
community this happens to Reddit this
happens through Twitter this happens
through Facebook the number of people
that are like it's you know that if you
just accept every person who oh you yeah
well it so many pictures of freaking
women in bikinis trying to add men right
now it's ridiculous and I'm sure the
opposite is true for women getting tons
of men as well for in men these profiles
you click them open they're from some
random City they might have a mutual
friend or two of yours because they've
already accepted the request but they're
trying to just mine your information
yeah and manipulate you through their
social postings that say things like oh
this certain news is being propagated
and then you click it open it's some
random site that has no actual
authentication and all of a sudden
that's what we're seeing more and more
of so who's doing this
who's doing this who's behind this why
are they trying to manipulate the fabric
yeah
what's their incentive what do you mean
why are they trying to manipulate the
fabric because it is the most powerful
form of what people are trying to
control or the actions of other people I
mean this is actually warmer it is in
because the the war that they're waging
is in your mind
yeah there's no more powerful form of
violence than violence that you are
responsible for that's that's the
ultimate form of an accountability
especially when you don't know that it's
happening to you that's even worse for
those who are causing the violence
it allows them to remove or revoke any
kind of accountability that they have in
the situation you go through seven other
people to hurt another person and the
way that that person actually gets hurt
is that they hurt themselves or they
hurt someone else most people who do
that aren't even aware they're not even
aware that they're becoming violent that
they're either going on these you know
they're going on this like whole train
or they're like wanting to you know
they're spewing hate speech or they're
doing whatever where they feel like they
they hate this other person and they
want to fragment the community where
they feel like they're at odds with
someone and this person is their enemy
and that's by design it's not actually
because this person is your enemy it's
by design it's because you're being
manipulated by everything that you don't
see and understand but it's getting to
you because they know how to get to you
that's why you can't even read don't
even read it's don't don't even engage I
don't I don't I barely use any of that
stuff yeah yeah and if I do I like don't
it's just really don't even engage with
it no I mean I don't for the benefits of
vocalizing your perspectives to the
world which actually helps a lot to put
good content at the sphere a lot of
times I hear people say that I'm not
using social media anymore because it's
just too much of that nonsense but then
I also say that you are a brilliant
person that has a lot of wisdom to
communicate to the world if you just
took those little bits
wisdom that come to your mind and post
them across Facebook Twitter Instagram
LinkedIn these major platforms and just
posted it there and then just let other
people read it and see it they would be
like wait there's actually good content
on here too and then we could over
overturn that as well I want it I want
to ask about how what you're building is
restoring that media fabric and this and
not enabling the fracturing to happen so
easily well I'm not actually building so
I can tell you how it should be done
it's a platform that I created you know
it's it's like I can tell you how it
should be done I actually have a few
talks that that mention essentially
here's the solution to this Jesus but
that's not what I'm working on because
I'm working on something from a
different perspective and a different
angle it's just about being aware that
these are the real problems and this is
these these are the real political
issues that are affecting citizens as
well the holy their baby they're way
bigger and broader issues than that but
these are the ones that are at least in
our control
what were your talks that you give how
do you get the awareness in though just
from that point before we go to what
you're building what how do you wear
nurse and other people how do you get
the awareness in so that people maybe
stay skeptical or stay super analytical
don't get driven by those emotional
signals that come through the you need
to ensure self transcendence I mean it
self transcendence you have to be so
aware of not only it's not like what you
are and what you are not you just have
to be so aware of our relationship to
existence from a cosmological standpoint
that you're able to take a God's eye
view on some of this stuff because
that's the only way you're gonna that's
the only way you're gonna make it
through yeah if you start looking at
things super myopically and you start
focusing on the trauma you start
focusing on the pain you start focusing
on the anger you start focusing on the
sadness you're gonna it's it's just
gonna keep existing because you're
focusing on it if you focus on the pain
the pain will continue to exist if you
focus on the light if you look at things
that's grinning I'm not saying it's not
like I'm perfect and it's not like I'm
like I always have this
active and I'm like unaffected by
everything like it's not that's not the
case I'm the person and I just try to
maintain it's in the past like I've you
know I've seen a lot of things like that
and I hear you with the
self-transcendent perspective yeah I
just have to keep checking yourself yeah
it's it's a recently posted about the
importance of the mirror the importance
of really looking in the mirror and
focusing on self growth and being very
careful and being like I actually don't
like that and then working on it and
being okay with other people critiquing
and being really driven to to work on
oneself okay so how about what you're
working on with Chris Allen so tell us a
little bit about this this is really
interesting so web of trust is
essentially and so the company my
company is called culture and the
foundation of the work that we're
building is essentially universal access
to legal contract rights outside of one
particular jurisdiction and a shift in
our relationship to identity as
something that is stewarded by a
community instead of 'no psyche owns as
a biometric or something like this so
web of trust is an open source standards
running underneath culture and culture
is essentially the ability for you to
register your identity on web with trust
you can register it on like civic or
Junio order through Facebook and social
media or whatever right and you can pick
and choose which identity if not
multiple identities you want to use to
interact with the world and then you
essentially have access to all of these
different blockchain applications and
landscapes so I can have multiple
identities this is and this is a
philosophical question that we can get
into right whoa so with with web of
trust it's essentially the idea that
you're now we can get really into that
conversation because that's a
philosophical debate I have to submit a
DNA sample per personality it might get
that extremely well and in a digital
world might be the only place where you
can have an anonymous identity let's
hope it doesn't but it's it's already
but then but then how would really if I
could take five different personas
and identify them through through a
platform then we're already experiencing
a little bit of fragmentation of sorts
because whatever the four ones that
aren't this good standing one could do
whatever they want with the plow so what
are you quick ly though on the
philosophy behind that would our yeah so
I mean and this is a tricky and complex
question because there's the idea that
you should only have one identity like
that's basically Facebook's stance it's
like you should only have one identity I
thought about this last night like I got
into a deep sometimes I get I just write
and I get into like this deep
conversation with myself about our
relationship to identity but it's the
idea really in our system that your
identity is stewarded by your community
and your identity is not only relative
to your identity but what's really
important about your identity when
you're participating in different
communities and cultures is your
decision-making power so you might have
a bunch of identities and then of those
identities may have decision-making
power in any of the cultures of the
tribes or the communities that you
interact with so should you have I mean
this is not here's the thing like it I
don't I don't know if that something I
feel should be just like there are
certain people like activists so for
example so to give you an example of
where this would be important interest
so if I'm living in Uganda and I am a
you know let's say I'm living in Uganda
and I'm gay and I want to marry my wife
because I love her and there was a
period of time where you got I was
trying to pass a bill fueled by the way
by Western fundamentalists who came to
Uganda like super like hard-line
Christian and they essentially hardly I
don't want to say Christian activists
but I think that's probably how they
would think of themselves they came to
Uganda fuel to hate movement and you
gotta try to have passed they kill the
gays bill and so they now have an anti
homosexuality law where essentially if
you you it used to be the death penalty
and now it's literally life in prison
it's that bad so if I'm living in Uganda
and I want to get married
anonymously and have my community verify
it maybe gain access to some services or
some rights or some anything some
whatever you know collaborative
governance marketplace can provide for
me then I actually can't I I'm putting
my life at risk okay if I have a public
identity and I'm saying that because the
world has not reached the level that
you're at the rest of the world has not
caught up with what you've reached okay
you got it maybe either give them some
time or like figure you have to
essentially figure out a way to there
are people are already living is to life
so so there's a good way to leverage
five fake personas that you control to
try and increase the amount of
conversation in Uganda around Pro gay
marriage no that's not what I'm saying
and it's also the idea that if you have
an anonymous identity and that anonymous
identity isn't having any kind of
interaction you can be banned so like if
let's say a communities organize thank
you legally gay married with an
anonymous identity yes when I'm when you
use your anonymous identity you're not
necessarily using an anonymous identity
frequently to interact with the world
but you'd use your anonymous identity to
register different contracts anonymously
that you and your like social network
can verify or the you and your partner
can verify so you can have legal access
to a system of contract law that exists
outside of the bounds of a jurisdiction
that may try to oppress you for owning
your rights right so there's one really
important yeah right there that's the
highlight when do that's the reason why
when a jurisdiction outside of use
trying to oppress you in some way you
then have the ability to privately put
something on the digital ledger securely
over time and and that and then you're
on publicly you can do go to the grocery
store etc because that's not oppressive
of sorts yeah that's but can you
continue to keep like if you're using
like these identities first of all like
they're all stored in one place right
and you can have one identity like your
civic identity as a public identity
where you need to follow KYC naml laws
and you need a passport you might have
another identity like through web of
trust where you're a refugee but it's
the idea that all of these things can be
transparent and linked and you can see
when someone is using an identity that's
not a transparent identity so you might
immediately see
like hmm okay well this person who's
trying to interact with me I don't know
them and they're just using an anonymous
identity so if I'm a journalist I might
say this might be a tip right from an
anonymous whistleblower but if I'm just
a person and I'm interacting with
another person and they come to me
directly
just anonymously I can say no like or
maybe I'll let like one message through
but I can say like no like I don't
really want this anonymous person with
no reputation or no identity to be able
to contact me like unless they are you
know doing this or this or this so the
way that that works is essentially if
you have an anonymous identity and you
want to connect with someone you need a
party of trust so the way that this is
outlined even in the white paper for
Amira that's written for the web of
trust foundation is that it's the idea
that Amira is an activist from Syria who
was a child bride that escapes her
abusive husband who has a position in
Syria and regime she moved to Boston she
has a job at a bank that's a normal job
but she wants to give back to the world
and so in wanting to give back to the
world she engages in the situation where
she sees this guy on TV and she's like
wow he builds like he's building this
app that's gonna shelter women that have
been physically abused to really want to
contribute but she can't contribute
thank you she can't contribute with her
own identity because she doesn't want to
be a rich doesn't wanna be found by the
regime she doesn't want to be any of
these things only she contributes with
an anonymous identity called better
world hacker 23 but how is he even
worked at the bank without showcasing
her identity she's Social Security
number
she's these things production I mean
this price I mean they can be it can be
different kinds of things and you can
also I mean the assumption in this case
is that they would be looking for her
and then and with this kind of heritage
or background it would be someone that
would yeah so okay so this is about
protecting one's own health as well from
for having this independent agency to
move away from oppression somewhere else
and then not be under the attack of that
regime but the important element of this
is that if she's using I'm not talking
about that identity the identity that
I'm talking about for her that she use
our system for is the anonymous
that she would use to essentially say I
don't want to use my public identity
because I feel I could be at risk so the
only the way that she connects with him
like she could reach out to him using
her anonymous identity but probably have
like low latency so she finds a mutual
friend who knows him that knows that
knows the guy who's running a non-profit
and the mutual friend essentially says
ouch for her there would be a lot of
connections and say yeah it might be
right I can vouch for her and say it's
gonna be complete the system is trail of
vouches for the person you can you can
have a trailer like the six degrees of
separation or connection and you can say
well I trust this degree at this level
or this person at this level so you can
have this person essentially say
Charlene introduces her to this guy Bob
and she says I can vouch for betterworld
hacker 23 and say that better world
hacker 23 is like an excellent
programmer and so he says okay well
let's engage in this agreement and I'll
you know for the first month show me
that you're a good coder contribute work
to this project for free then they
create an agreement then once he says
you're a great coder she gets to
continue to contribute to the work
because he says okay she's right you are
a great coder and then what happens is
he starts building up her reputation for
her anonymous identity okay so it's not
like anonymous identities exist in a way
right now what's happening is that we
have anonymous identities that are able
to proliferate at this regard because
there's very little accountability but
if you place an anonymous identity in
the hands of a community that's
stewarding it yeah then the model shifts
because you're actually saying my
identity is not just my identity my
identity is the way I exist subjectively
it's also the way I exist objectively my
identity is the communities of reference
that I associate with and my identity is
also the skills I have to offer the
world so you start to get this portrait
of who a person is that's beyond just
one the sum of one username or handle
you're actually saying I exist as a
process of the way in which I relate to
the world around me and in that way once
you're able to gain perspective on that
we're moving people closer to the idea
of what it means to take this kind of
God's eye view Insull transcend so it's
it's the idea that we really once you
change the model to community
stewardship a person who is seen or
perceived
it's being anonymous you and you might
say you might feel comfortable talking
to anonymous people oh you might
probably and you might say yeah sure
like I don't need an anonymous profile
as well I have things that I'd like to
contribute outside of the the social
fabric that I think would be very very
inspiring that other people should hear
but that I do choose not to right now as
much of an open book that we are here
there are many things that we just
cannot say on the program that we would
like to say is that right yeah I've got
nothing died no I don't care I don't
need to be anonymous interesting so then
there's people that don't care at all
about anonymity and then a lot of most
people most people don't at all those
people want most most people have known
me my god I would publish the most crazy
medium post about civilization design if
I could just be totally anonymous topic
I mean I'll probably say my anonymous
friend asked me to be like I wouldn't I
would never have an anonymous identity
because I just don't
I'm like so full I would never have for
me I don't really have a need like I'm
transparent like I hang out with my I
say this is like a joke because my I'll
give my friends passwords to my stuff
and I'm just like here you go I'm like
here they're like oh do you like want to
unlock your phone and I'm like there you
go
and they're like people are kind of
taken aback and I'm like listen I don't
care if you I don't really have anything
I hide I don't care if you read my
emails just as long as I'm consenting as
long as I'm consenting to you doing yeah
that's one thing but if I'm not giving
you the consent then there's a problem
and that's really what the our
relationship to anonymous identities is
gonna be based on consent and it's gonna
be based on community stewardship so you
have to consent like you can say as a
person through this identity like I
consent to receive messages from any
kind of identity any anonymous identity
should I consent to allow anonymous
people into our community but it's that
layer of consent and you're starting
with that layer you're setting the
balance first and you're setting the
boundary so if you're like you know I'm
I want people in my community if you
can't be who if you can't show your real
identity or you can't have
one who's in our immediate circle vouch
for your identity then that's an access
point that we're gonna put over here and
you can be a part of those communities
that have these different standards but
if you want access to our community are
we have these requirements for access
it's kind of like you know being an
accredited investor so let's unpack the
example again because I think it's
really important to do so so we have a
woman that may have fled an oppressive
regime that now works in within the
United States with a public identity
just working normally just in case
anything happens but she finds something
that is very inspirational but that
could get her in trouble so she finds a
private identity and anonymous identity
and starts working with that
organization through a connection
network that enables them to say okay we
trust we trust we trust okay sure start
coding okay coatings good enough maybe
she starts getting paid by them she
starts contributing to them that's good
stuff so that's an example of an
anonymous use so there probably will be
uses of this anonymously and this
profile will get built up and so that's
really good so that's is that would you
say that's your primary case example of
culture of the importance of what you're
building
so I'd say that's the importance of of
web of trust web of trust is free web of
trust will always be free it is an open
source standard for people to own their
rights sovereignly outside of the bounds
you can use this for refugees of a
particular jurisdiction so if a refugee
wants to gain right now essentially the
the process for immigration is a lottery
citizenships basically a lottery you
sometimes money helps yeah money helps
with pretty much everything and but if
you're a refugee and you don't have any
of that it's basically a lottery whether
or not you'll even get chosen so what
we're actually doing is saying listen
we're creating this open-source research
and development institution and this is
helping everyone make more effective
decisions because you can actually see
if you're letting a person if you're
saying well I want to let this person
into my community or into my like you
know property or my country or
whatever may be a country that exists
maybe a country that you create then
you're able to say okay well I can
actively see this person as a part of
these communities so we share some
common ground over here and there's I
can also see that this person has these
skills so interestingly ties into Trump
saying that he wants the best refugees
are the best immigrants and not just
whoever the hell wants to come in
well the immigration process is
absolutely if it's horrible across the
board this is why you have people going
into new nations and like I I went into
Denmark I think about a year ago and I
was like what because I hadn't been back
in like a couple years and I went there
a year ago and I was like oh my gosh I
was like I called one of my friends and
I said what's the deal what I'm like
what's going on I was like I've never in
my life seen a homeless person in
Denmark oh wow I've never seen a
homeless person in Denmark and she said
you're not gonna like the answer and I
was like I don't know I was like well
you got it I think you gotta tell me why
what is it and she said they're refugees
they're refugees and it was just so I'd
never had someone approach me on the
street and ask me for money in Denmark
just never and so it's also a process
where even these nations that have like
these incredible you know programs in
social democracies or things like this
and essentially like the Roman flag is
like unity through division it's like
this big cross and then when you look at
all of the scandic nations they're all
basically the Roman Empire leaning to
the left and then Jesus is like the
Roman Empire at the pinnacle of power
meaning one is greater than the other I
mean all symbolism is literally
everywhere and so yeah and so it's one
of these situations where if they
actually were able to understand listen
okay here's this refugee and they have
skills as a carpenter
they speak English they have effective
skills as a teacher they've been
teaching people in refugee camps we have
these forty people they grew up with who
can verify that they had this job where
they did this thing then they're
actually able to see okay not only or
can we like admit you but let me like
actively place you into a job yeah let
me
like get you a place to stay with people
who you share a common community with
that are willing to open up their house
and then let me help put you in a place
where you're gonna actually be able to
meaningfully contribute to society in a
way that you're skilled or build your
skills yeah and so connections so
important yeah it's huge yeah because
you know we a lot of people are coming
into these environments where it's like
imagine if you're new in a place and you
don't even speak the language and you
just like lost half your family and you
saw your house get bombed and you come
into a new country and you're like you
don't even understand that you have to
pay to write you know do I pay to ride
the bus so guys you not been on a bus I
don't know what this language means and
you're alone and it's like you're any
any person you when you go into a
grocery store you might have taken in
everyone you look at you're like no one
here understands me everyone is staring
at me I feel like I'm being ostracized
you're just walking down the street
celebrating my culture and I said I
actually proposed the solution at a
broad scale because people were talking
about this and we were all concerned and
I said have you ever like considered
that maybe we should just throw a giant
party and everyone was like this was in
like a government office everyone just
look to be in there like go on and so I
said you know have you ever hung out
with someone where you're like you've
got this totally different background or
this different experience and the way
that you bond is that you just share
something social and meaningful together
yeah
like when I went to college a drink or
an event or but beyond is is celebrating
someone's culture like when I went to
college we celebrated Holi it was like
everyone's favorite day of the year like
you see all of these like Western kids
that have never been to India and they
have all these like they're like got the
typical College photo of them like
covered in the Holi paint dust right
from the celebration of spring and in
that way you feel like this you because
you've had an experience with that
heritage you feel connected to it yeah
and so I said have you guys thought
about going through and actually taking
the holidays or the celebrations from
this culture and just celebrating them
throughout the city
organize a big party because then people
are gonna have empathy because they're
basically like oh I've I've not only
broken bread with this person but I've
broken bread with their tradition yeah
yeah and it's beautiful it's like you
know you where you will show you what
Christmas is like - right so that's the
the foundation of this is really about
humanizing our relationship to each
other and placing ownership more as a
student - a stewardship role taking the
attitude of developed nations and
actually uplifting what's meaningful
about First Nations about indigenous
nations right because if we took more
time to steward our planet and the
people that were in it I think we'd all
be a lot happier healthier and way more
connected adding someone as a friend on
Facebook doesn't mean you are connected
means you're linked yeah I liked how you
said that's not just about breaking
bread but it's also about breaking into
their culture than breaking into yours
and doing something to ensure that
across the planet we always think that
is it really gonna take a an alien race
identifying one outside of Earth to
finally realize that we're all one here
I hope it doesn't take that long until
we really figure out how to work
together and help each other so so
alright let's cover the examples of
let's do this quick because I want to
get to a couple quick questions before
the end let's get to the examples of the
influence that culture is having in in
identity we did we did identity with
anonymity and non anonymity and then how
about voting property all this other
kind of stuff what yeah so are these the
other major uses property marriage
contracts education certificates
basically anything that you can register
is a universal registration system the
original function of the nation-state
was essentially just that like I was
basically the function of jurisdiction
it was a way to organize things because
we had tribal kings
who essentially organized things with
their memory so you remember what I said
about memory earlier it's like the
tribal Kings memory isn't perfect or
it's not it was paper Ledger's sometimes
yeah I mean then it's like oh well and
then it moved into kings and queens
where it's like Oh everything's
organized because I own it oh so we
don't even have to worry about that and
then you made it into and then we make
it into nations which nations
essentially say well we're trying to
give people different forms they still
have kings and queens basically like you
know the Kennedys but it's or like
regimes is used in different contexts
but it's a regime and yeah it's it's the
idea that you're giving everyone access
at least to buy a house or to do a thing
and you're giving them a kind of
ownership over their registration which
is controlled ownership so what we build
is Universal registration where we're
all I'm also wearing it's my necklace as
well
you are the logo yes nice you got one of
those I'll get you something that's cool
yeah we should hang one up in here yeah
let's do it but it's also the idea that
you're you're now having the universal
registration
we're putting jurisdiction into the
hands of every person on the planet as
an individual and the way in which we
look at ownership isn't just the idea
because it's like if you just register a
contract on the blockchain does that
mean anything like no but when doesn't
mean something when people are organized
that's when it means something whether
for bad like I was talking about earlier
with those psychological insurgency
networks are for good to give people
access to their rights and ownership
over their rights we can use that evil
for good we can use that evil forget
that's part of the foundation of the
system that we're designing and so yeah
that's it's it's that's what's core to
culture and then on top of culture is a
really dynamic ecosystem for new forms
of access economy and community because
the future of government is not
government the future of government is
culture
yay nice nice so it's good good all
right now we've touched on at least an
okay amount of what we've needed to
touch on about your background and about
what you're building into the world and
importance of it so how about a little
bit of simulation questions so let's ask
you about I'm interested to hear your
thoughts on this one we're approaching
an age of massive information technology
across biotech and crypto and space and
AI and robotics there's so much
technology and it's kind of exacerbating
the wealth inequality and we're now
getting close to about eight people have
as much wealth as four billion what do
you think is going to happen with that
gap of wealth and equality how do we
help that and then also what's going on
across the world with these technologies
with the China Russia us equation yeah
unpack that a little for us with your
thoughts yeah so I mean there's a
philosophical way that we could talk
about ideologically how this could work
and then there's the reality of the idea
that all of these countries might try
and homogenize and control their own
things so okay which one do you lean
more in the direction of it depends on
how organized people are frankly and it
depends on how much we like to play
together rather than separately yes
exactly
united we stand legitimate I hope so on
earth I hope I hope so yeah for sure I
hope so
so addressing the idea of this kind of
like emergent well I mean the this is by
design as well you know we have a third
world country pretty much in the United
States mm-hmm drive through San
Francisco if you'd like to question
whether or not that's true yes
sixth and market just drive through I
have seen through maybe like I could I
could take you to at least five to seven
side streets that are literally probably
actually more than that that are
literally just homeless villages yeah
they are started making
is that of like like like shanty
structures fancy structures outside of
like wood just basically wood tents or
things like that like propped up with
sticks and there's there's a hole
there's hold there's 10th row
there's Hazzard Needle depositories San
Francisco spent 30 million dollars this
year cleaning up needles and feces from
the street yeah and then you have Rincon
Hill which is [ __ ] right over there
by the Bay Bridge where a condo costs 25
million dollars rent for a one-bedroom
apartment
is five thousand dollars if you factor
in what the salary is for most Americans
and how much it costs to live in San
Francisco you you wouldn't be able to
eat living here so yeah I mean it's a
obviously a very serious problem and I
think the way that we solve these issues
is by giving people access and I think
that what's gonna happen is all of this
information and like people talk about
the foundation for ubi and the
foundation for ubi is actually the
quantification of information and the
individuals ability to take ownership
over their own data because your data is
a resource like I was talking earlier
with your body whether the data that you
generate is content whether the data
that you generate is your biological
information maybe you have a very unique
eye color maybe you have a very unique
genetic patterning where whether the
information that you generate is
measuring the quality of the air in your
area maybe the information that you
generate is living in Africa and you're
using your cell phone to take a vr like
essentially using your cell phone to
scan the world around you in a way that
runs it through a program that can
immediately translate it in real-time
hopefully into a virtual landscape so
you're essentially creating the empathy
machine by just showing people this is
what it's like in rural Sierra Leone and
maybe that's a form of you're
contributing meaningfully to society or
to a project so the way I think this
will play out and this is really good
for your data yeah for anything we've
been talking about ubi being the data
being the source data you generate being
a source for ubi
as long as people actually pay you
hopefully hopefully we get well the
systems will be designed that way and if
they're not designed that way then
if someone said you could get paid for
this or not get paid for this you would
take the option that said I would like
to be paid for it it's really that
actually simple especially when the
information is stored on an ax
blockchain in a way that can make the
information anonymous just just as
information right the only people who
would have access to the information
would be intelligences you can have a
network of decentralized artificial
intelligences that are running on top of
this network and they're essentially
looking at the information as our
relationship not to our subjective
identity but as informations
relationship to other information yeah
and so if you needed subjective help you
could have a personal AI that is
specifically for you all of these AI
should be decentralized consciousnesses
we don't actually do no damn daily from
synapse I know she's definitely yeah but
we don't fear AI we fear the
centralization of power so if all of
these things are decentralized they're
solving problems together rather than
saying like all AI is owned by one thing
that's what we fear because absolute
power will be absolutely abused absolute
power destroys absolutely and so if you
have a personal AI it can know who you
are and then all of these other AIS can
be invisible processing information and
mining meaning out of that whenever AI
is just like whenever an ASIC ship
solves a math problem and that math
problem generates an answer and that
answer generates meaning in the meaning
generates Bitcoin where essentially
we're changing the process of we're
going from like I said its value and
information into meaning through meaning
and wealth wealth and meaning right so
whenever we're able actually generate
meaning from that information then we
can have the distribution of wealth and
we're all generating meaning all of the
time in pretty much every moment and you
have access control over how much of
your data that you want to give out and
then there's these benevolent AIS that
are running to figure out what is the
meaning coming from the data okay so
this is potentially a solution to the
wealth inequalities people actually
getting paid for their data they're
contributing whether it be your
biometrics or whether it be taking that
VR video within yeah within a specific
place in the world or any kind of
generating content like what we're doing
right now like attention yeah I am every
every variable that exists in the world
time our relationship to the way we move
through space perception attention
meaning emotion reaction our emotions
our information the way that I react to
us if you say something to me and I
react in a certain way that's actually
meaningful information yeah if you react
calmly if you react calmly versus if you
react agitatedly yes that's very
important information especially for
when they test astronauts for the
International Space Station cool or even
growing from that what might actually be
valuable is that one time someone says
something you and you react in a certain
way and then another time someone says
something to you and you respond
differently and your reaction to the
situation shows that you've grown so all
of these things like the idea is like
also that the amount of information
we're processing so constantly people
think that information is like what is
seen like you put a blog post out like
that's doing something like that
information is what's unseen as well
that's really well said yeah yeah
because the the exactly your reaction if
you've grown as a human through your
reactions that's that's or if we're
doing some natural language processing
on your work and we're seeing that
you're writing about things that are
maybe a little bit more higher level
you've been reading you've been learning
oh you get a little more money for your
data good job the invisible information
economy will generate infinite well
mm-hmm I like that
all right let's let's jump you into do
you think we're alone in the cosmos I
don't know what it means to be alone I
think that all forms of consciousness
are connected I think the cosmos oh so
the question is interesting for me
because the cosmos are a consciousness
so the very relationship of the language
in that question to its answer are at
odds because are we alone in the cosmos
like the cosmos our life there a
consciousness themselves just like Earth
is a conscious
are there advanced civilizations roaming
the cosmos the Kosmos are in an advanced
civilization in and of themselves the
cosmos there are higher
are there more advanced civilizations
than ours roaming the cosmos it's it's
the same relationship the relationship
we have to the broader higher
consciousness of the cosmos is basically
the relationship we have to earth it's
like we're right in the middle of these
two four and they're both pretty
benevolent right and so if you look at
earth it's like if you there's an
experiment from Harvard it's like one of
my favorite things to reference in terms
of people saying I've had people go like
Earth is a consciousness like Doug
sounds really and I'm like the if you
speak to plants differently mmm they
will grow differently you play different
music if you look at a plan you like I
hate you plant and you look at a plant
you're like I'm they respond yeah the
earth is a living breathing organism
that actually created human life but
from space you can literally see the ice
caps melting and they're sure making
snow and melting snow it looks like
breath yeah even though Earth created us
she's not the full source of life we are
more of the cosmos than we are of apes
we as a human race were more aware of
the cosmos than we are apes yes yeah
okay sure but it also seems as though
we're all of that at the same time
though but I wrote a haiku a while ago
and it's the tides of life are a cycling
progression meant to merge man and God
yeah that's good I like that haiku
that's a really good one yeah so I think
that what we're experiencing as a
consciousness is we're essentially just
spiraling upward and outward and like
art here's what's happening like our
consciousness was here is like this
little dot and our consciousness is
going like this
and then it's just continuing to expand
until we reach a point of expansion that
can compare to the cosmos so it's a big
galaxy forming over - yeah and then one
system all of our consciousness reaches
that it's like we but we are we're
continuing to go through that cycle at a
micro scale and then there's also that
cycle happening at a macro level it's
the same relationship that we have to
the Hindu perception of time we talked
about the Hindu perception of time is
categorized into four yugas this is also
related to Mayan astrology and Mayan
astrology having the calendar that says
the world can end in 2012 they didn't
actually mean the world is gonna end
what they meant is that that era of time
is coming to an end between 2012 and
2018 right it's the end of the Kali Yuga
which is what I call the Golden Calf age
it's like materialism degradation like
false idol worship we just finished the
Kali Yuga and we're entering into the
South Sioux Yuga which is the Golden Age
where the gods and goddesses reign and
these periods of time are actually
relative to Earth's relationship not
only on its own like wobbly axes kind of
thing the definition of a wobbly axis
but not only Earth's definition to its
own rotation but Earth's definition of
its rotation closer to and further away
from the center of conscious energy in
the universe so we're moving back toward
that center of conscious energy in the
universe which is what gives our own
humanity I really shouldn't ship to what
I call like Second Sight or even like
sacred geometry if you look at like the
pyramids the the you know sacred sites
and in Mexico and in Cusco and there
when China and an Egypt like if you look
at Giza and you take the face of an
Egyptian statue and cut it in half and
then you flip one side of the face and
overlay it I mean it's literally and
then you overlay that with the original
image it's literally perfectly
symmetrical we were able to do this
because our consciousness was in a
higher state and then all of a sudden
it's like what happened is we started
taking all this information that we
experienced right like we started taking
the experience of higher consciousness
and instead of experiencing it what
happened is people try to start owning
it they started to grasp it right and
they started to try and use this to
control because we were no longer in the
connection in it that high point
energy with the universe we were moving
away from it and when people start when
we start to move away from the central
to the center of conscious energy in the
universe what happens is we start to
essentially crush our own minds into
into this kind of like it's like we're
here and then we expand then we expand
outward and then we're contracting and
then we're expanding but we're going
through that process over and over again
in one broader spectrum that is a
continual expansion of consciousness
until the metter meta perspective of
what is like our quantum relationship to
consciousness reaches again the same
point that our initial consciousness
experiences every like series of four
Yuga cycles that we go through
I like how you describe the vicissitudes
of consciousness because I don't think
the ups and downs of consciousness are
described at a meta some civilizational
level most of the time they're described
at a individual level so it's good to
see and feel them really contracting and
expanding contracting because I we do
discuss quite a bit on the show the
previous tribes of humanity that have
been very conscious and so why are we
here now with yes ubiquity in food and
water in many cases but also the
proliferation of the media culture yeah
okay do you think we're in a computer
simulation it's not a computer
simulation the simulation is our
relationship to your own consciousness
it's funny to me because man okay so
someone else is not altering playing
with the code of our program listen it's
funny to me because this is how like man
contextualizes things right man looks at
a thing and it's like especially in this
age and we're taking what exists as an
inherent property of our consciousness
and we're essentially giving our power
away and saying like the world is just
runner created by a machine could me
know this isn't an Asimov story like
good I love as a mouse don't get me
wrong all the spirituality could be
programmed as well but it's it's the
simulation is that where we're merging
back into our relationship with higher
conscious
us so what's happening is we're
experiencing our own quantum perception
in real time because the age of shifting
it's not a computer computers are from
us you know what I mean computers are
from us yeah it's like fire
it's like programming of the quantum
world and the string theory yes the
programming of the quantum world is
happening from consciousness computers
are a reflection of consciousness that
the idea that we are like are we in a
simulation
yes but the simulation is that what's
happening is we have four bodies that
exist at once okay we have our real time
body that exists here we have the body
that we experience in dreams which is
our non-physical body which uses
non-physical energy and then we have our
quantum consciousness it is the version
of ourselves that exists in a higher
dimension that's able to watch over us
through a lens of time that is not
relative to material space we exist in a
quantum state right we exist in in not
only two places at once being here we
exist in two places or maybe even more
at once in the universe they say like be
a witness like that's you tuning into
what's actually happening upstairs
so it's it's really about the idea of
our relationship to consciousness it's
our relationship to consciousness is a
simulation we're just waking up to the
fact that we we perceive time falsely we
think that time is well not falsely it's
just relative to the dimension of the
age and the dimension of our
relationship to the consciousness and
the center of energy in the universe we
think the time is like a line like
Western time as a time line or Eastern
time as a circle even the you guys are a
circle but it's not a line or a circle
something closer to it dot now we've
been hearing razor blade on the show a
little bit time is happening all at once
all around us at once and we're able to
access this percent this is why I teach
people lucid dreaming we can access this
perception of time in dreams yeah we did
a little astral projection on our
previous show
just a lot very last one so okay Tony
Lane question about what is the deepest
emotion you've ever felt
hmm I don't think there's a word for it
was what was the feeling like because
it's beyond the idea of the deepest
emotion I've ever felt is an idea that
there is an emotion that is beyond the
sum of feeling because it's an
out-of-body experience mm-hmm
people quantify that with words like but
they are overused words that I think
people represent falsely like what is it
like bliss or love or ecstasy or any of
these other you know I think it's the
most real emotion I've ever felt because
it's the thing that makes you more aware
of the idea that you're existing beyond
your own physical body beautiful island
so source is how I would describe it
mm-hmm source is the deepest and most
intense feeling I think I've ever felt
source source yeah I like that a lot all
right what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world
there is no most for me there is no most
you know what I actually think is
beautiful what other people perceive to
be ugly but it's but it's true of heart
that I think is the is the real
definition of beauty easy is not what is
just seen as beautiful real beauty is
when you'll see something that is
beautiful and that is hidden mmm the
rest of the world looks on this this
book called by Umberto Eco called on
ugliness and it's maybe my loved art
history and it's maybe my favorite art
history book that's ever been written
because it can textual eise's ugliness
and art in the way that almost all other
art historians work to contextualize
beauty
and that real beauty is like Cyrano de
Bergerac
it is the man who is ashamed of the way
that he looks hiding in the bushes
having another man read his poetry to
the woman that he loves in an attempt to
help her be happy yeah that's good stuff
that is the beauty you know why that's
real beauty because that is the beauty
that more than any other form of beauty
needs to be seen yeah appreciative yeah
yeah I agreed that that brings
actualization to people that brings
transcendence to them it brings them
meaning and value and fulfillment from
their tribe
I agree that's that's good that's very
unique we haven't had that one for sure
also the source answer was really good
as well yeah Tony Ling Casserly wow what
a great conversation yeah yeah you're
fun yeah good yeah thank you for coming
on the show thank you thank you sure
thank you this has been such a pleasure
I think that we have a lot to still
unpack you'll have to do another session
sometime soon yeah so much to unpack
that was a lot of fun everyone if you
had a good time watching definitely
share this content please share it we
need more people talking about these
thought-provoking subjects join us
subscribe hit that subscribe button join
us in the community give us a comment
below with your thoughts give us a like
join us on patreon we need to sustain
our studio need to sustain our
electricity our food our internet all
that stuff join us let us grow help us
blossom
we need people chopping up these videos
and getting these clips join us there
we'll have Tony Laine cassowaries link
in the bio all good description there so
we will see you soon thank you for
tuning in
[Music]
you